today is the second week of in-person
learning for some ccsd students
it's just the start of the district's
plan to get everyone safely back on
campus before the end of the school year
we have bianca holman live with us this
morning with some concerns that parents
have
as the students transition back to class
bianca
hey good morning john so all ccsd staff
and teachers they'll be back on campus
in about a week and then in a few weeks
the fourth graders through 12th graders
and like we're here at bonanza high
school they'll be back in the classroom
but with that hybrid model some parents
they still have issues with it
and so of course they've been expressing
those concerns to us and
one potential problem is that ccsd is
selecting
student groups based on a survey parents
filled out that was back in september
the district says it needs to lock
things down like transportation plans
and doesn't have time to do another
survey
but as rebecca garcia of the nevada pta
points out
a lot of things have changed since then
and some families want to switch their
group from last year
more public health statistics have
changed the vaccine is now available and
all of us who filled it out in november
aren't getting a chance to change our
response
so secondary schools they're going to
follow that same hybrid model as the
elementary school
students of course being split into
three groups some go on campus monday
and tuesday others on thursday and
friday and then of course there's a
third group that stays learning online
from home but
even students who go to campus will only
take two classes in person and then
they'll finish the rest of
the rest of their classes remotely now
safety is still a big concern
we learned that last week there were
eight staff members who tested positive
for coronavirus
although the district did not say if
those individuals were
working remotely or if they were people
who are working from the campus and or
teaching students so that information
has not been shared with us
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now